it's been saying oh yeah you can do
cheese and I'll just forgive you
everything will be okay later
no no it's not work Beyonce does not
bootiful living in a world of hookup
culture people are constant looking for
something better or what's next you
jay-z just dropped an album addressing a
lot of the rumors we heard on lemonade
so I'm just gonna walk around the office
can ask could you forgive someone for
cheating on you yes I have cheated on
someone I don't think they know I have
not been cheated on
to my knowledge one time that I'm aware
of I've actually been cheated on on two
of my serious relationships I've
definitely been cheated on and I've
definitely cheated to be petty I can
understand why people would cheat it
doesn't make it right but sometimes
things happen in life and like I feel
like emotional cheating is actually a
big thing even if you're like thinking
of someone in a way like that is to me
that's treated almost I feel like if
you're a rapper or basketball player is
this easier you can't help your
attraction but with that being said your
attraction should not be open while
you're in a relationship if you feel
like you have to cheat up like you
should just get out of that relationship
if I'm married I'm not gonna leave my
husband for cheating if it's something
like that happened once does that mean
you get back together with them and
forgive them enough to keep the
relationship going
or do you forgive them enough where it's
like you're kind of okay with the
choices they've made as a person I
really forgive somebody if you have a
family or you have some sort of like
history our past I think it's tough that
people just leave that behind
as a single person with no children like
from me cheating it is a deal-breaker I
would forgive them because I should how
I am and that's my morals but I would
not stay in a relationship with them
obviously your life is now devoted to
like your kids and your family but you
at the end of the day need to be happy
forgiveness is the way to move on and
grow but it's really different
[Music]